so it's too bad we don't have anything
to talk about today that's the
understatement of the century
why don't we start out by talking about
Harvey Weinstein because that's sort of
the story that's everybody's talking
about right now and as every day some
new atrocity occurs and yesterday or the
day before whenever it was three more
people came forward with the idea that
he had raped them and this has been
going on for years and years and years
and there were eight settlements against
him and obviously everyone in the
company knew about it and you know I
have to say I wonder about his wife who
I gather last night announced that she
was leaving him finally how she could
possibly not have heard about this but
how how do you think this happened I
mean how was this allowed to go on and
on and on and have nobody ever speak out
until now because as a society and as a
culture we protect her a sir's and if
somebody can actually tell me why that
is that that is the that's the twenty
million dollar question why why do we do
that no is it because we're protecting
our own jobs is it because we're
protecting a person in power I think
those are the two top reasons but now
that the floodgates have been opened you
know I just give so much credit to the
women who were able to tell their
stories and by the way eight settlements
there's probably more eight that have
been reported well eight settlements but
that doesn't mean that there were only
eight people that have a molested or
assaulted or raped I mean we know there
were three other people who were raped -
who have come forward who have not
reached settlements and what is the
statute of limitation on rape well this
is the problem well rape is a crime so
that's right there
you know that that is a longer statute
of limitations but we're through the
guard to sexual harassment you don't
have a
time to file a claim you don't know it's
different in every state and it depends
on whether or not it's a it's a federal
violation or a state violation so you
know that's another thing that we need
to look into I mean there's so many ways
in which we should look into laws to
help women more women come forward but
especially with an issue like sexual
harassment where you don't just
automatically switch on the light and go
hey I think I'll come forward you don't
really have a lot of time it's it's less
than two years but you said you know
power and jobs but that doesn't excuse
the men in the company and the people
who were on the board and other people
who the lawyers and all of the people
who had to be involved in those
settlements with those eight women had
to know about it why did they not say
anything I don't you know what and and
who are they I mean are they want their
names on the front pages I do well I do
see a Washington poet that's what we'd
have to fill up every newspaper that
ever existed because it's not just that
company yes no I know that's not just
that company where it's happening
they're covering this up in hundreds and
maybe thousands of companies across this
country and across the world so the big
question that you ask is why do we
protect the harasser what I have found
out from my research in my book is that
it's not how was the most powerful
person at the company that we protect we
sometimes even protect a low-level
employee who's a harasser I'll give you
an example somebody comes into a job and
they're warned hey be careful a Joe over
there
he's been here for thirty years he has a
rude sense of humor sure enough the
woman finds out who Joe really is she
goes to complain and who do they protect
Joe no he's not he's not a central
person to the functioning of the company
he's not the CEO of the company but they
protect Joe and that woman is phased out
so it's at every level you know but
Sally I have to tell you that I feel
buoyed by the Harvey Weinstein's story
oh you should absolutely well but I mean
not just you we all do yeah that's what
I mean I was I mean I was horrified but
I was also thrilled that this came out
that he was outed that that he got
fired from his company that they're
gonna take the name of the company's
name off the company that he's going
into therapy and thrilled that his wife
was leaving him I mean I think that he
should be shunned and I think that this
is a huge step forward for all of us who
have had these experiences and we all
have we all have and it's a step forward
for the enablers the people that you
mentioned who will also be called out
and you know what they're gonna feel the
shame that all of those women have felt
and they shouldn't have exactly those
people are gonna feel ashamed enablers
are a huge part of this problem and a
huge part of this solution and actually
sexual harassment training in companies
should focus more on enablers than
almost anything else yeah we should
focus on how do we give the courage to
the enabler to not be the enabler and to
also come forward it's crucial you know
I I said to you earlier I was reading
your book I just got madder and madder
and madder and madder it makes you crazy
and you're reading one story after the
other and you keep thinking this can't
be happening this can't be happening it
can't be happening today and yet it is
so I mean the reason we're here is
because of your experience at Fox News
and your sexual harassment suit against
Roger Ailes and I know that you can't
talk about it but I can I know yeah and
so I just wanted to read in your in your
complaint Ailes has unlawfully
retaliated against Carlson and sabotage
her career because she refused to sexual
advances and complained about severe and
pervasive sexual harassment Lal is
retaliation against Carlson in various
ways as described below including by
terminating her employment on June 23rd
2016 and prior thereto by among other
things ostracizing marginalizing and
shunning her after making clear to her
that these quote problems unquote would
not have existed and could be solved if
she had a sexual
addition ship with him when Carlson met
with ales to discuss the discriminatory
treatment to which she was being
subjected Al's stated quote I think you
and I should have had a sexual
relationship a long time ago and then
you'd be good and better and I'd be good
and better adding that sometimes
problems are easier to solve that way
Carlson rebuffed tales of sexual demands
at that meeting and nine months later
ales ended her career at Fox News well
first of all he was so repulsive the
idea that someone like Roger Ailes could
even think that he could get away with
that that he would that he would be
attractive enough to anyone to even take
him up it were it not for the outrage of
what he was assuming but one of the
things that the reason that you can't
talk about it is that you did resolve
this lawsuit and and you reached a
twenty million dollar settlement and as
far as I'm concerned that was not enough
but why can't you talk about it I mean
is that not part of the problem in a way
that you know in order to reach a
settlement that you had to agree not to
talk about it right and just as a caveat
with regard to the resolution I'm giving
a significant amount of that money away
to my gift of courage fund to help other
women I just want to be clear about that
and all the proceeds from my book are
going to gift of courage settlements yes
this is the way in which our culture has
decided to resolve these kinds of cases
over ninety percent of sexual harassment
cases end up in settlements and what
does that mean that means that the woman
pretty much never works in her chosen
career ever again and she can never talk
about it she's gagged now how else do we
solve sexual harassment suits we put in
arbitration clauses and employment
contracts which make it a secret
proceeding so again nobody ever finds
out about it if you file a complaint you
can never talk about it
ever nobody ever knows what happened to
you in in most cases you're also
terminated from the company and the
predator in many cases is left to still
work in the same position in which he
was harassing you so this is the way our
society has decided to resolve sexual
harassment cases to gag women so that we
can fool everyone else out there that
we've come so far in 2017 and the reason
that we think that we have come so far
is because we're not hearing about these
cases but the reason we're not hearing
about the cases is because the women are
silenced either through settlements or
through forced arbitration so suppose
you had said you know I want to I'm
bringing this case and I want to settle
but I don't want this silenced clause
would they have said go away they would
have yeah I mean I was given the benefit
of being able to talk about this issue
openly and share other people's stories
and talk about ways in which I think we
should change laws and have this very
conversation right now that is rare so
in order to what do we do to change the
this happening to someone else where you
can file a sexual harassment charge and
then you can reach a settlement but the
settlement does not include silencing
you yeah how do we go about the first
thing we need to do and this is the work
I'm doing on Capitol Hill is we have to
take forced arbitration clauses out of
employment contracts or at least take
the secrecy out of it I'm working
diligently to get a bipartisan bill on
that because sexual harassment 8
political Sally before somebody harasses
you they don't ask you what party you
belong that's true you know and that
this is why Republicans and Democrats
should care about this equally for their
daughters their granddaughters their
nieces and I've been meeting with many
of them privately to try and get them on
board to support this bill to take the
secrecy out of it so how does that
change the landscape that means that if
you're sexually harassed then you can
file a public complaint and you can have
a
trial which is your seventh amendment
right the way it works now is that if
you file a complaint it's secret and you
go to arbitration where only 20% of the
time does the victim actually win and
it's not like an open court system
besides the secrecy you can't call the
same amount of witnesses the depositions
are different there's no appeal and the
people hearing the cases are retired
lawyers and judges who may not be as
adept at understanding sexual harassment
in this particular generation where they
may well but the most they're mostly men
yes well that's what I'm saying
well and so maybe they're not going to
side with the victims is what I'm saying
so we need to start there if I can just
get a bipartisan bill to pass that takes
the secrecy out of this that's a warning
shot to companies but you can't hide
this kind of behavior anymore right so
explain to me why this isn't a
no-brainer
I mean when you go up in the hill and
you talk to members of Congress and you
say I want this arbitration bill like I
want this changed why would anyone say
no oh because I mean give me give me a
good reason what they will say to you
number one big reason is because
Democrats are in favor of this and
Republicans support big business and so
basically do they say they're their
little girl we are supporting big
business I mean how do they raise it
well let's just say this they're taking
the meetings with me they are oh yeah
and they're listening and I think that
that they are thinking long and hard
about the ramifications of their own
children mm-hmm I mean this is why I did
this whole thing otherwise and some of
them have even told me that their wives
have been sexually around course so I
mean I think this is why people are so
frustrated with politicians in general
is that they speak out of a lot of sides
of their mouths so on the on the one
hand I think rationally
they look at this and they realized they
should be on board okay but then they
have a whole nother constituency that
they have to try to this I mean what
let's talk about silence so the big
business guys because I'm sure there are
guys will go in to talk to their
Republican senators or congressmen
they'll Lobby them and they'll say you
can't do this and the reason you can't
do this is because we're sexually
harassing these women and they'll sue us
and we'll lose a lot of money I mean
that's probably not bad blatant get your
peers that's that's the only reason that
they could be against it well the
argument about arbitration is that it's
cheaper for the employee so you don't
have to hire you know a whole bunch of
lawyers and go through a long process of
a trial that's not really true there are
a lot of costs associated with
arbitration and also the biggest thing
is that big companies will say that
we're doing a service to unclog the
courts because the courts are already
overworked oh they're cool they care
about the courts and so this is a way to
solve small business disputes by putting
them into arbitration that those are the
arguments that are given to the employee
but see here's the problem when you
start a new job you're just happy to
have the work and get the paycheck
you're not thinking about an arbitration
clause and you're not thinking you're
going to get into any kind of a dispute
I know I never thought I was going to be
there and so then when you do and you
suddenly realize you don't have your
Seventh Amendment right anymore that
that's a daunting day because you
realize you really don't have any
options and your rights have been taken
away from you and that's what I'm
explaining to these members of Congress
so I'm optimistic about it you this was
not your first experience tell me a
couple of experiences you had before
when you were 22 you had two or three
experiences that were pretty disgusting
right yeah unfortunately this isn't my
first day at the rodeo yeah it was it
was when I was Miss America actually and
maybe the blessing of that was that I
had built tough skin because when you
accomplish something like that
suddenly my resume of being a concert
violinist valedictorian Stanford grad
who also attended Oxford evaporated and
I was just dumb mm-hm and so your dumb
blonde dumb blonde yeah I forgot the
blonde part so I had built thick skin a
lot during that year but towards the end
of the year I started meeting with
television executives because I realized
this was a career that I wanted to try
and one executive was so nice to me all
day long he made so many phone calls for
me and we went out to dinner and I
thought wow this is gonna be a great
beginning for me and when we got into
the back seat of the car service to
bring me back to my friend's apartment
suddenly he was on top of me with his
tongue down my throat
and I remember being panicked and
thinking how the hell am I gonna get out
of this and I screamed for the driver to
stop and I opened the door and I got out
not knowing that all where I was and got
to my friend's apartment and just lost
it in emotions and what so many women
have gone through what did I do
why would he do this to me didn't he
respect my brain wasn't he really trying
to help me all of that just goes away I
never ever spoke to him ever again so I
guess he really didn't want to help me
and unfortunately a couple of weeks
later I was in Los Angeles and I was
meeting with a high-powered publicist I
was a go-getter you know I was knocking
on all the doors trying to get a career
started and unfortunately I was in a car
again with him and he took my head with
his hand forcefully jammed my head into
his crotch so hard that I couldn't
breathe
that's it really attractive I know I'm
sorry to pause what he actually don't
know what what do you wanted me to do
you know this is better than high scores
and candy yeah your here's the really
here's the really fascinating part about
this I never really spoke openly about
those stories until recently but more
importantly it was a friend when I was
telling her those stories who said to me
you realize those were both assaults and
I said what are you talking about
she said that's assault and I had never
defined it that way before and I think
it speaks volumes about how we normalize
this even as women in culture that we
think we can overcome it and so we just
put it aside and we don't really
acknowledge it for for what it is and it
was actually Natasha stoyanov who told
me that she was she's interviewing Isaac
right story yeah she was one of the
alleged Trump victims right
and she said what happened to her was
assault well why don't you you know her
so she I tell her story and be fierce
because she was fierce and she came
forward all those years she was a People
magazine you support People magazine
reporter who was at mar-a-lago and doing
a story about the impending birth of the
president's latest child with Melania
what they were doing this they were
together yes and she says that when
Milton Lonnie went up to change her
clothes that he took her aside into a
room and forcefully kissed her and
against her will and she actually took
herself off of that over a year don't
because she inch but she told people
which is huge and it's my advice in the
book you need you need to tell PETA
People magazine at the time you mean
People magazine right and I'm telling
and I'm saying in general right women
should tell people right a human being
another what happened because because we
still live in a he-said she-said culture
and so she's the one when I was
interviewing her for my book when I was
telling her what had happened to me and
she was the one who told me it was
assault and then she came forward with
her story she came forward because she
was listening to one of the debates
where the president had said that he had
never forcefully kissed anyone against
their will and she thought I don't want
to be silent anymore so she came out
with it and she they had she had been
friends with melania and then she ran
into Melania on the street and they
kissed and hugged and Melania said we
haven't seen you in a long time where
have you been and after she came out
with the story Melania denied ever
having she said she didn't know they
never ran into each other it didn't
happen so I mean what do you talk what
do you say about the the wives who are
enabling their husbands to do this kind
of thing I mean Melania is a perfect
example and you know I don't know about
Harvey Weinstein's wife Georgina Chapman
but as I said I can't imagine that she
didn't have some inkling of this after
ten years of marriage well what I would
say to them is that I hope that they can
find a way in their heart to also be
fierce and to stand up for who they are
as women and give themselves more
respect so you mentioned that Jane Fonda
had had several experiences what were
her experience well she just came out at
79 years old and said that she was raped
earlier in her career she's and she's
Jane Fonda I know and she interested and
abused and and she had never told those
stories before so see this is the
culture we live in where these kinds of
stories are stuffed down and women are
made to feel ashamed that something
happened to them when in essence they
were shamed right and so we have to turn
this issue totally in the opposite
direction I but I do sense it's
happening now well I do too I mean we
also I mean Gwyneth Paltrow came forward
and so did Angelina Jolie and I have to
say God loved Meryl Streep for speaking
out against Harvey Weinstein who she's
worked with
but the issue of shame really fascinates
me I've had as you can imagine as all
women have I've had a number of
experiences like this one when I was 19
when Senator John Tower took me was
supposed to take me to lunch and then
ended up with dinner and I should have
known better and then we had dinner and
then he took me to this bar what I
shouldn't have gone and then we got in
the cab and he jumped in the cab he
tried to rape me in the back of a cab
and I did I was so ashamed I cried for
days I didn't tell anybody for a couple
of years and then later when he came up
for I but I'd started telling people and
when he came up as to be nominated
Secretary of Defense I had these two FBI
agents come to the house and say we've
heard about your experience and we're
checking on Towers resume and when you
tell us about and I said this is totally
confidential and I said you know if I
happen to know that it's not
confidential because I work for the
Washington Post and we get our stories
from you guys and as it turned out he
was voted down and Nancy Kassebaum the
only Republican voted against and
because she had heard my story and then
poor Anita Hill who you know is a
perfect example of this didn't have my
experience her background she didn't
know better and she talked to the FBI
and she told their story and of course
they subpoenaed her and she ended up on
Capitol Hill and her life was ruined and
I could have been Anita Hill
I mean her life was ruined she's now a
punchline she's now Anita Hill and
that's all you know about her
never mind that she's a distinguished
lawyer I had a casting couch experience
where the producer hired me to be the
girlfriend of the movie flipper about
the dolphin and he said and he said
literally but you'll have to sleep with
me if you want the part and I said well
I'll have to ask my father and I didn't
get a call back
and I had the producer of 60 minutes
went sent me over to London to cover
Princess Anne's wedding and said I'm
gonna make you a star and he flew over
and you know helped me and make
and hair and all that kind of thing and
then took me to my room one night and
threw me against the bed on the bed and
you know these are stories that I never
told right away and then I did write a
book about my CBS experience and
mentioned this this the CBS one but I
never told that the John tower story why
or that because I was ashamed I was
ashamed because I thought and I just
said to you I shouldn't have agreed to
have lunch with them I shouldn't I was
19 I shouldn't have agreed to go to
dinner when he dragged me across the
street to the nightclub I shouldn't have
gone somehow I should have managed to
keep him out of the cab it was my fault
it was my fault I mean but I see
yourself feel that and I still feel the
same way about the producer 60 minutes I
mean what was I thinking I mean he was
gonna help me be this big star and I
just started out on television and I had
no experience and but I should have
known better it was my fault that I led
him on and it wasn't yeah but you see I
mean the the John tower thing I still
feel ashamed even to this day so how do
you how do women get over the shame of
thinking that they bruh I mean we all
want to look attractive we all want to
you know I want to look sexy when I go
out at night and and and dress up and do
my hair and makeup and I want people to
think I'm attractive but where's the
moment when you know you cross the line
where you're coming on or you're asking
for it as opposed to you just want to be
an attractive woman well women I don't
think women are ever asking to be
assaulted and now what I say in the book
is that you can be wearing a short skirt
hospital scrubs or army fatigues it
doesn't matter and you should not feel
any shame no woman should but shaming is
a potent force so I talk about that how
do I get over the shame part of it well
how we get over it is that we'll talk
about me talk about it yes and now we're
seeing I've even seen some people say on
Twitter well Gweneth Paltrow for example
didn't come forward right away so so we
should discount what she's saying now no
that's that's the other
but but no because this is how it starts
we should never shame a woman who comes
forward at all I don't care when she
comes forward that's right ever we
should then realize that as these women
start to come forward even if these
episodes happened 30 40 50 years ago
that's right I don't care when it
happened as long as you start coming
forward you encourage other women to
come forward when it's happening to them
now right that's how it works it's a
chain of inspiration one woman at a time
we bolster the courage the courage is
not something that you just suddenly
wake up one day and go hey I think I'm
gonna do this monumental thing it is a
process it's a process of time it's not
a light switch and that's one of the
greatest myths that I've seen on my
social media is well why'd you wait so
long why'd you wait till it was all over
that that is such a naive and ignorant
question because you don't realize you
don't realize where women are still in
society we're still labeled
troublemakers we're still labeled you
just can't take a joke we're still
labeled the B word we're still not
believed and the best one is that we
just bring all these cases forward
because we want to be famous oh right
[Laughter]
well but I have never met any of the
women that I've spoken to who that was
their reason for wanting to go as you
talk about like 40 for me it was 40 over
40 years ago with the John tower thing
over fifty years ago and I never told
the story until last year when I did
Tina Brown's women in the world summit
and I told the story and I was on with
Kerry Washington yes
in front of thousands of women and I
started telling the story and I thought
I was gonna lose it I almost started to
cry because I'd never told that story
before
at this point in my life I know and so I
can only imagine I mean that was I
waited so long to tell that story now
does that make it less legitimate
as I waited that long no no that's the
point is that mino' its shame you don't
want to talk about it you somehow feel
embarrassed it's your fault you don't
you don't want to bring that sort of
attention on yourself you don't want
people to think you're a troublemaker or
a complainer or whatever and it but I
agree with you I think that the idea of
people talking about it when it happens
and telling people now you know the
feminist point of view is and I agree
with this that you know if you say it
happened it happened and it should be
done however there is this other side of
the story and it happens occasionally on
college campuses and that is what
happens if somebody is falsely accused
and this is an issue and I think it's
something that we can't pretend doesn't
exist I I happen to know this because a
close friend of mine son was one of
those boys at Duke University who got
thrown out right for harassing this
woman it turned out that she had made up
the whole story and lied but his life
was ruined I mean he was thrown out of
college and all that kind of thing and
and so I have a lot of friends in mine
who have sons in college who basically
say you know you ought to keep stack of
permission slips on your bedside table
with the pen and make sure that the
people women sign it if they're going to
have sex with you how do you protect
your sons and how do you I mean you talk
a lot in your book about your children
and what to tell your children and how
to make sure that boys understand yes
what the rules are and and how far you
can go and what you can do but there's
another side to it which is sometimes
the boys are innocent I think in a lot
of cases when you're talking about men
sexually harassing women particularly in
the workplace it's a whole different
situation all different situation
totally different I acknowledge I
acknowledge in my book that yes there
are false accusations however it's a
very small percentage of the problem one
in four or five girls will be sexually
assaulted on a college campus that
doesn't make me feel good with two kids
who are preteens no nor should at any
parent who's about to send
they're children off it's one of the
reasons I'm doing a college campus tour
with this book because you have to get
to kids young to form and shape their
opinions and the way in which they look
at the world one expert told me in the
book that if you start trying to change
the way men perceive women when they're
in their 40s and 50s forget it it's too
late
so the main mission for me now is to get
to the kids at a young age so that
they're building their perceptions and
their respect for women while they're
growing up that's why I do a whole
chapter on parenting yeah I mean it's
essential I actually have always said
I've worked more for my son than I have
for my daughter because I want him when
he gets into the workforce in twelve
years or so I want him to look at his
female colleagues and respect them the
same way in which he looks at me now and
respects me and my kids were the most
important decision in what I decided to
do when I jumped off that cliff
the only thing I was thinking about is
how will my kids be I mean it was huge
probably the biggest decision of my life
to do what I did and I would not have
done it if I thought I would have harmed
my children and in the end how could I
have ever known how any day would be
after that day with no safety net I had
no way of knowing but I have now seen my
children get that gift of courage
themselves specifically in my daughter
who was looking for courage in certain
aspects of her life and when she went to
school on the first day after that
summer happened to be the same day my
resolution was announced I was very
anxious about it and she came home from
school and she said mommy a lot of
people were asking me what happened to
you over the summer and she said mom I
was so proud to be able to say that you
are my mom that's right what was the
tipping point for you because obviously
you'd put up with it and put up with it
and put up with it and put up with it
and and and the most insidious part was
I mean here you were getting higher
ratings than anybody else and
you know doing all these incredible
interviews and I mean you know you were
obviously a hard worker and you were at
the top of your game and yet they
started lowering your salary and taking
your your show away from you and moving
you into a different time slot and
taking the interviews away from you and
where was there a moment where you just
said I'm mad as hell I'm not going to
take it anymore what well Sally first of
all thank you for acknowledging all of
that thank you it's a very lonely
experience and so I thank you for giving
me that credit when I finally realized
that what I had worked so hard for more
more than 25 years towards when I
finally realized that that was going to
come to an end for me I realized that I
had to do this not so much for myself
but for any other women that were going
to come after me and that I wanted the
next generation to not have to face the
same indignities that I had I mean that
was really that was really what it was
it was seeing that what I had worked so
hard for was going to go away
but was it was it gradual I mean I mean
I know sometimes when I make decisions
it's something that I mull over for a
long period of time and then suddenly
I'll think yep wait a minute you know
I'm gonna do this or I'm not gonna do
this or I can't take this anymore or
whatever else it is mm-hmm
so I can't talk specifically about all
my emotions and all the years and what I
went through there but I can say in in
general terms for women that I often
think that we are so used to working
extra hard that we feel like we can
change the dynamic if we just work even
a little bit more hard right and so you
keep hoping that they'll finally see you
for who you really are I often think
actually that stronger women are worse
victims because of that we're so used to
banging our head against the brick wall
to get ahead
and we persevere against all odds that
we keep fighting instead of saying
something that's the dynamic that needs
to change but it must have been I mean
it must have been humiliating for you I
mean what what about your colleagues I
mean at Fox I mean didn't people say hmm
I wonder why Gretchen just lost the show
that she had the hot that we had the
highest ratings on television I don't
get it mm-hmm
you find out who your friends are yeah
and how did that happen I mean were you
disappointed and some of your friends
were you surprised at the support you
got from some of the people yeah I can't
talk about the people at Fox yeah but no
no I don't think I can read about all
that I mean just in terms of in terms of
people I mean just in general how people
behaved when they saw what was happening
to you it was it was really fascinating
I'll tell you a couple of things I heard
from people that I hadn't heard from in
30 years who I never expected to hear
from that was amazing you mean
supporters yes mm-hmm
some of my own neighbors never reached
out to me that was the flip side of it
some people came up to me after time had
passed and said you know we just didn't
want to trouble you we just didn't want
to bother you
you know we didn't know what to say
sometimes that happens when people die
yes you know people sign a sympathy card
just their name and my father had always
said to me when you send a card you
should always write memories of the
person because that's what the person
wants to see not just a name I'm not by
any stretch of the imagination equating
a death with what I went through when I
was a little death yeah but it's not the
same as totally losing somebody's butt
but what I'm talking about the
phenomenon is the same in the sense that
people don't know what to say to you so
they say nothing yeah well you do go
through the stages of grief mm-hmm PTSD
yes which is exactly what you're talking
about that you're still experiencing
I'll bring it full circle to that man
who jammed my head into his crotch where
is he now
guess what 25 years later I saw him
walking down the hallways of my place of
employment and I panicked yeah and I ran
up I slammed my office door I started
sweating I was shaking I mean this guy
wasn't going to come in my office and
put my head back in his crotch but this
is what happens to you you forty years
ago for you you know twenty-five years
ago for me
you don't forget that moment of sheer
panic and being out of control and
somebody violating you and I mustered up
the courage after a couple of moments to
crack my door open a little bit to look
out into a hallway to see if he was
there and then I ran as fast as I could
to the elevator I mean it's what do you
think that he even remembered it
probably not if he was doing it all the
time yeah you know and this this is
another exactly yeah yeah it's
normalizing it within within culture it
brings us back to enablers action you
know and why it's so important for
people within companies to say that is
not acceptable what you just did
imagine if Billy Bush had said that in
the Donald Trump tape yeah I'm not gonna
stand for this mr. Trump at the time I
don't talk that way to women you see if
somebody would just do that in a
corporation there's no way he would have
done that yeah I mean he was this young
guy and he was trying to get ahead and
Donald Trump was Donald Trump and it
just wasn't good so now I think that's
going to start happening I really do
especially with our younger people
Millennials want to see that their hard
work pays off in a good way they like to
see end results and I really believe
that our younger people especially want
to get rid of this indignity I really do
and I think that with more and more
women coming forward that is so
empowering to women of all ages but
especially our young women who are just
coming into the workforce they're seeing
what happens when other women are
speaking up and they're seeing that they
have a voice when you
but when you look at politicians and you
see for instance well first let's start
with Jack Kennedy and my husband was a
very close friend of Jack Kennedy's he
and his wife were and they would have
dinner two or three nights a week at the
White House and Ben swears my husband
was Ben Bradlee who was the editor of
the Washington Post and then he was at
Newsweek but swears that he never heard
any of the rumors about Kennedy because
the four of them were close friends and
so it wasn't something that came up and
so he didn't know about it and later
when he started reading all of these
stories
he was really shocked and just after
Kennedy was killed and shocked and
disappointed and and then that story
came out about the woman that he'd had
an affair with in the White House when
she was 21 and and he had forced her to
have oral sex in the White House pool
was several the White House staffers and
and yet here's this person who is
revered all over the world by everyone
and and and he was this extraordinary
man there's no question about it but he
was a predator of the worst kind so that
makes him not an externally that's right
and then you know you have Bill Clinton
and you know the women who are the first
to stand up and say or were the first to
stand up and say if she if it she says
it happened it happened suddenly with
Bill Clinton all the women were liars
it didn't happen all of his supporters
and he was a predator and then you have
Donald Trump and Bill Clinton is still
revered and you have Donald Trump who is
you know so blatantly out there with
this that he even talks about it openly
and and and and in fact while he's
married talking about it and I'm coming
on to women like this People magazine
reporter and 37:4 well the majority of
people in this country well he not the
majority but he was elect
president despite that and that you the
people who were interviewed said oh well
that's you know that's locker room talk
or and Melania saying oh that's just boy
talk well it's not it's not in that
promulgates and it's not it's boy talk
it's not locker room talk it's not I
mean I don't know any man who talks that
way I just don't at least I don't think
I do but I haven't been in a locker room
lately but but but the point is that
that he's revered by many people in this
country and they don't seem to care
about that so what do you do about
changing the the culture in the sense
that that people will look at Donald
Trump and say simply that is not
acceptable and and anybody but
particularly in the president United
States because is that what the mothers
of his supporters are saying to their
little boys this is the president you
know he can do what he wants to do so so
can you it's a terrible example for our
children and I think so what do you do
it well so I the way I handled that
personally is that I showed my children
that tape you do it did because I
thought it was a teachable moment for
them and I know that millions of other
parents across the country were
grappling with what the heck to do with
that and I hope they used it as a
teachable moment I wrote a New York
Times op-ed about that right after he
was elected and said this to me I don't
really give a damn about any policy that
you're trying to pass or what party you
belong to to me human decency supersedes
all of that and that tape showed me what
human decency was not and that is what I
shared with my children when they so did
they understand what he was talking
about yeah mm-hmm you know in schools
now they help they talk about that
terminology I mean that did I want to
show it to them no but I felt that it
was imperative to show it to them now
whether or not people think that
tax policy or immigration policy or any
of that is more important than human
decency that's why we live in a free
country and they can vote for whomever
they want to I worry that those comments
have set us back dramatically but aside
from that I'm optimistic with where
we're heading because of more and more
relations of these other stories coming
out I wonder if what's happening now
with with Weinstein will make other men
particularly women and other men just
look at this and say this is enough
you know we've we've this has gone on
too long we can't do this anymore I mean
have you heard any it's only it's so
recent but let me see it how do you and
I think that a huge part of the equation
and I talked a lot about this in the
book an entire chapter dedicated to men
men who defend well that I was just
about to get to that because I wanted to
know about the men who defend I mean who
are the men who were out there fighting
with you I mean I I'd seemed to me I
read that George Clooney had said
something about Harvey Weinstein did and
it reflects so far yeah
but the men in my book range from
journalists to men who have made this
their life mission to go in companies
and teach them to be more equitable with
women in the way in which they treat
them with more respect there are tons of
men out there that are doing good work
for women and here's why it's so crucial
the responsibility of fixing this
problem should not only be on the
shoulders of women it's not only our
responsibility to make workplace safer
for us it's actually more of a men's
issue than it is a women's issue
so we need these men to be on our side
to help make change and as long as we
still have 94 percent to Fortune 500
companies run by men we especially need
them to be on our side in the way in
which they pay us in the way in which
they promote us in the way in which they
decide whether or not we get a seat in
the boardroom and the way in which they
may or may not sexually harass the
so men's voices are critical to making
change and that's why I feel even though
it's been only a couple of days to see
men come out and say what they've been
saying we must support these women and
we must stop enabling this that's huge
it's like a cascading effect right I
really believe that we are on the
precipice of a major change with regard
to this issue I think Harvey Weinstein
may have been the tipping point in a way
I mean it was just so egregious and had
been going on for so long and it had
been kept quiet for so long and then
suddenly it's it it just defies the
imagination that this could have been
happening in this day and age and that
and that people were accepting this and
enabling us but I you know one of the
things that I think is in in terms of
sort of fighting this is to sort of
create an atmosphere of sort of the
creep factor what's that well I know
when Hillary Clinton was talking about
you know Donald Trump sort of hovering
around her during the debate and she
said I'd you know I wondered whether I
should just say just get away from me
you creep because he was a creep you
know I mean only a creep would say what
he said on the access hollywood tape and
if suddenly I mean it's kind of like
smoking you know you you know at one
point you know every smoking was really
cool and now you look at somebody who
smokes and you think oh my god the poor
guy you know he's addicted he's weak he
can't or woman you know and they're
gonna get cancer and they're gonna yeah
I mean you just the whole our whole
attitude toward smoking has changed that
you would simply look at a man who would
do shove a woman's face in his crotch
and say you're a creep and I'm gonna
tell everybody what a creep you are
right and so these guys would be even if
they didn't realize that it was wrong or
they didn't care or they felt entitled
or whatever that they would be so
terrified of being called a creep or
what I think
I kept in my imagination last night when
I was reading your book and getting
really angry and I thought you know we
ought to have every newspaper should
have the creep of the week but I
actually think you're smoking analogy is
a really good one mind if I use that
from time to do all yours I actually
think you can also have the creeper okay
that's a great analogy because I see
that in my kids right yeah they look at
smoking now and they're like mom I think
how that person smoked and it's so
outrageous to them right well it's
discussed okay so I'm gonna use that as
my barometer for this issue of sexual
harassment and I'm gonna hope that in
the next few years or 10 years or 20
years that that's the way in which we
will be looking at it I mean there was
there was a guy who was sort of a very
powerful guy in Washington still around
you know and was sort of well known for
putting his hand on women's thighs under
the dinner table at these fancy
Washington too and nobody ever said
anything I mean we all used to talk
about it I mean he never did anything
more than that and it was it was creepy
and it was embarrassing but it was kind
of like urine in the middle of a
black-tie dinner you know with candles
and everything else and the guy starts
this puts his hand on your thigh and and
you just sort of don't know whether to
say just cut it out you just you know
and every it would have been so shocking
and and so but it was it was kind of a
joke but I can't look at this guy and
not think about that well you still tell
him remember you told your other stories
first where I see hope on that look at
somebody like Taylor Swift yeah okay
she's in her 20s do you think she wanted
to take time out from her world tour to
go testify in a sexual harassment and
roping case no probably not but I am so
glad she did because she is sending a
message especially to young women that
she's not gonna take that crap right
right right she is the person who is
standing up and saying get your hand off
my thigh how dare you
my butt right that's what she said that
I think also played into this whole
narrative of how we get to this tipping
point if I jumped off the cliff and then
Susan Fowler came out at uber and then
more people in Silicon Valley and then
you had the Sterling jewelers case and
then you had Taylor Swift and you had
actress Amber Tamblyn too and now you
have Harvey Weinstein look at how far
we've come in just 15 months so here's
the question in terms of getting this to
stop there to area there are two issues
here one of them is that the guys will
be scared they'll be scared to do it
because they'll be called out and also
because they'll be humiliated and people
will think they're creeps but the other
thing is how do you get them to become
decent human beings how do you get them
to realize that this is not decent
behavior and by the way some of these
people are evangelicals and Christians
you know I mean that and religious
people who tolerated the most and you
mentioned that briefly in your book but
there's a horrific story and a book
about a young woman who write was
allegedly abused by her minister right
and she just came out yeah and this is
not an unusual story among you know
among religious congregations and
certainly we've seen the sexual
harassment situation in the Catholic
Church but so where where you can you
can stop people from I mean that people
won't commit crimes because they'll
they're afraid they'll get caught but
only because they're afraid they'll get
caught and so these guys may just not do
it because they're afraid they'll get
caught in the embarrassed but how do you
get them to realize that this is wrong
it's that goes back to our original
point of how we raised them yeah so a
lot of it has to do with the mothers and
the father the mothers and the fathers
or whatever the family dynamic is if
it's a single parent or its partners
together kids see and hear everything
I mean I've even found myself Sally over
the last 15 months since my story came
out really really a ting how
parenting and exactly what I'm saying
what's my dynamic with my husband mm-hmm
because that's what they're seeing his
daily basis right so they're getting
cues from that but also our schools why
did that study come out that showed that
five-year-old little girls when they
heard something smart they said oh that
could be a man or a woman but by the
time they were six or seven they weren't
so sure if it could be a woman or not
what happens in a child's life between
five and six they go to school so what
are we doing in subtle cues at school to
make women already feel less and boys
feeling whatever more well you have so
this is crucial
you had one letter in your book where I
think it was your daughter who said mom
you should be President United States
and I think my son said that I love more
than anything he's now 35 and I was
married to Ben Bradlee who was the
editor of the post and was a very strong
man and Quinn said to me mom you should
be present so something must have been
going on in the family dynamics
even though Ben was a tough guy I love
to hear that I kissed it to finish off
that story she said it to me in the back
of the car one day and she said well mom
she said why can't you just decide to
run today I was like well it's a little
more complicated than that
I mean ironically I have been asked to
run for political office since this
whole story unfolded it's not
necessarily in the cards for me right
now but but Never Say Never now the only
thing you and I have to decide is are we
gonna be Co presidents or who's going to
be VP you know you had one statistic
that just blew me away and it was that
43,000 people are in the workplace are
raped or sexually assaulted every year
can that possibly be true yeah it's more
than that it's just because those are
the 70% of people don't come forward
yeah so yeah this is an epidemic this is
what I've been saying it's it's
alarmingly shocking
how much this is happening in our
culture you know my father once said to
me giving me advice when I first started
dating he said never never never
humiliate a man and that stuck with me
all of my life and I think he said that
is the worst thing you can do to a man
and I thought recently and I thought
particularly when I was reading your
book and getting back to this creep
factor thing is that the only way to
stop it is to humiliate the men who do
this thing to me because they can't
stand that their egos cannot stand to be
humiliated thank you daddy you know for
that but now you so you don't know what
you're going I mean you're doing this
incredible movement you're and and
you're testifying and you're speaking
and all of that kind of thing but what
do you think you will do I mean you
talked about how so many times when this
happens the women never end up back at
their the job of their choice or the
field of their choice what what do you
think your future looks like well you
saw the camera crews with me today and I
can't officially announce what that is
but a iconic Hollywood producer has
asked me to work on a wonderful project
with him which will be out this spring I
have all these other full-time jobs I
mean I'm really I'm a great organizer of
time but I'm spread thin with my fund
and the Leadership Initiative but I do
plan to go back into television you do
yeah I've worked my whole life I can't
imagine not working I want to work I
have a lot to offer I mean will it be a
day-to-day show I have no idea I've had
so many inquiries but I'm so glad Sally
that I've taken this last 15 months to
gain perspective about Who I am what I
did how that's all unfolded how my
children fit into the picture because
had I just decided to jump back into
television I wouldn't be doing all this
good work right now that's right yeah
and and I'm doing this because of the
thousands of women that I heard from
they never ever had a voice like you and
your stories they never told anybody but
they told me and I knew I had to do
something with
so that became my mission over the last
15 months life works in mysterious ways
it certainly does yeah and you never I
never expected to be the face of this
issue ever but the one constant in my
life has been that when there's a
challenge in front of me I go for it and
that's what I'm doing right now with
this you're being fierce I am being
fierce look thank you so much this has
been so pleasurable I would really
really really love you thank you